♪ ♪
>> Greg: MUCH ANGER AND
EMOTION TO BE FOUND FOLLOWING
FRIDAY SHOOTING.
TALKING HEADS ON SUNDAY SHOWS.
ENTERTAINERS.
>> YOU ARE NOT GOING TO FIX IT
BY TAKING AWAY THE RIGHTS OF
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS.
YOU'VE GOT TO FIX IT IN A WAY
THAT HARNESSES IT.
IF THAT MEANS FIVE METAL
DETECTORS, YOU GET FIVE METAL
DETECTORS.
>> HAVE YOU DONE ENOUGH IN THE
SENATE?
>> OF COURSE NOT BUT IT'S LIKE
EVERY OTHER ISSUE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE --
IT IS A THREE LETTER WORD, THE
NRA.
>> YOU MUST CONTROL YOUR GUNS AT
HOME AND BE SURE THEY ARE LOCKED
UP.
WE NEED TO GET DOWN TO ONE OR
TWO ENTRANCES INTO OUR SCHOOLS.
WE NEED ARMED TEACHERS TRAINED.
>> WHY DON'T WE DO MOMENTS OF
ACTION, CHANGE.
>> Greg: EVERY LOCATION WHERE
THESE OPINIONS WERE OFFERED WAS
WELL PROTECTED BECAUSE SOMEONE
CARED ENOUGH TO PROTECT THOSE
PEOPLE.
THEY CARED ENOUGH TO PAY FOR IT.
AGAIN THIS IS A LAUREL AND YANNY
MOMENT.
SOME PEOPLE SAY TOO MANY GUNS.
SOME PEOPLE SAY WE NEED ARMED
PERSONNEL.
POP CULTURE GLORIFIES VIOLENCE
LIKE VIDEO GAMES.
SOCIAL NETWORKS THAT EXPOSE
STATUS INEQUALITY.
A GENERATION DRENCHING
MEDICATIONS, BULLYING, NIHILISM.
IT'S EASY TO SEE COSTS AFTER A
GHASTLY EVENT.
ACCORDING TO RECENT RESEARCH,
SHOOTINGS INVOLVING STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN DECLINING SINCE THE
'90s.
IT'S WEIRD BECAUSE OF ANYTHING,
IT FEELS LIKE THE OPPOSITE IS
THE CASE.
IT LEAVES YOU SCRATCHING YOUR
HEAD.
WITHOUT ALLEVIATING ANY PAIN FOR
THE VICTIMS FAMILIES.
THE ONLY THING CERTAIN IS
UNCERTAINTY EXCEPT WHEN IT COMES
TO US, THE MEDIA.
IT'S BEEN REPORTED THAT THE
KILLER SPIRITS VICTIMS HOPING
THEY WOULD TELL HIS SIDE OF THE
STORY.
WHERE WOULD THAT STORY BE TOLD?
HERE BY US.
AS LONG AS WE DO OUR PART TO
TELL THE STORY WITH CEASELESS
COVERAGE FEATURING THE COWARDS
FACE A NAME FROM OF THESE EVENTS
WILL CONTINUE.
IT IS THE SIMPLEST CAUSE AND
EFFECT.
IF SOMEONE PERFORMS AN ACT FOR
THE SAKE OF INFAMY AND YOU
PROVIDE HIM THAT INFAMY, MISSION
ACCOMPLISHED.
IT'S A MISSION THAT LEADS
ULTIMATELY TO ANOTHER.
K.G., WHEN YOU SEE THE FACTS AND
YOU HEAR THAT MASS SHOOTINGS ARE
IN DECLINE, I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY
THAT WOULDN'T MATTER BECAUSE IF
YOU REPLACE MASS SHOOTINGS WITH
TERROR, IT WOULDN'T MATTER TO
ME.
I WOULD GO, LIKE, YOU STILL MUST
BE VIGILANT.
BUT THE THING IS, STATISTICS FLY
THE FACE OF WHAT WE EMOTIONALLY
BELIEVE.
>> Kimberly: SO TRUE.
WHEN YOU GET THAT, IT'S AN
EMOTIONAL SATURATION THAT'S
PALPABLE AND YOU FEEL IT.
I REMEMBER THE DAY ON THE LAST
SHOOTING, WE WERE ALL SITTING
HERE.
YOU FEEL HAPPY WITH THE EMOTION,
THE GRIEF OF IT.
IT SEEMS ALMOST LIKE IN RAPID
SUCCESSION.
YOU MAKE SUCH A GOOD POINT.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THESE THINGS
ARE WELL PROTECTED BECAUSE
SOMEONE IS CARRYING TO PUT THE
MONEY AND THE TIME INTO MAKE
SURE THEY ARE SAFE.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
I FEEL THE FRUSTRATION OF THE
PARENTS THAT HAVE HAD CHILDREN
SET OF BEEN INJURED OR MAIMED OR
KILLED BECAUSE WHY IS IT THAT
EVEN ONE MORE SCHOOL SHOOTING IS
ACCEPTABLE AS A CASUALTY OR
COLLATERAL DAMAGE?
WHY CAN'T -- IT'S NOT HARD TO
DO.
I WOULD HAVE DOGS AT THE SCHOOL.
I WOULD HAVE ONE POINT OF ENTRY
SO THERE'S SOMEONE COMING IN AND
THERE IS AN ATTACKER, YOU CAN
BOTTLE CAP HIM IN AND SECURE AND
PREVENT ADDITIONAL LOSS OF LIFE
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL.
YOU'VE GOT TO PREVENT THEM FROM
BEING ABLE TO GO IN DEEPER INTO
THE SCHOOL AND HAVING MORE
TARGETS.
IF YOU HAVE A METAL DETECTOR, SO
WATCH.
I WOULD RATHER HAVE MY SON GO TO
SCHOOL, OKAY, THROUGH A METAL
DETECTOR AND MAYBE HAVE SOMEBODY
THERE, AN ARMED GUARD, DOGS
THERE.
BECAUSE I KNOW HE'S GOING TO
COME HOME THAT NIGHT.
THAT'S HOW YOU HAVE TO PUT IT.
YES, IT'S NOT PLEASANT BUT IT'S
REALITY AND YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH IT.
IT IS LIKE NOT TREATING A
DISEASE.
BEING TOLD YOU HAVE CANCER AND
REFUSING TO TAKE A MEDICATION
FOR IT.
>> Greg: JUAN, THERE WAS A
SYMBOLIC SUGGESTION BY OBAMA'S
FORMER SECRETARY OF EDUCATION,
ARTIE DUNCAN.
THE GIST OF IT WAS STUDENTS
WOULD NOT GO TO SCHOOL UNTIL GUN
LAWS ARE CHANGED.
THAT WOULD KEEP THEM SAFE.
HE BELIEVES THIS IS A BRILLIANT
AND TRAGICALLY NECESSARY IDEA.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A POWERFUL
MESSAGE BUT NOT PRACTICAL IN
ANYWAY?
IT'S JUST NOT GOING TO SCHOOL?
>> Juan: I THINK HE EVEN SAID
IF IT'S NOT DONE ON A LARGE
SCALE, IT REALLY DOESN'T WORK.
BUT IF IT'S DONE IN THE LARGE
SCALE, IT'S THAT WITH AFTER THE
SAW AFTER THE EVENTS IN PARKLAND
WHERE THE VOICE IN THE POWER OF
YOUNG PEOPLE SING I DON'T FEEL
SAFE IN MY SCHOOL, MOM AND DAD,
IT REALLY DOES HELP TO GET
PEOPLE TO SAY WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
CHILDREN, OUR CHILDREN, OUR
FUTURE, SHOULD BE PROTECTED.
I WOULD SAY IN RESPONSE TO
KIMBERLY, I THINK THAT THAT
SCHOOL IN TEXAS WAS GIVEN AN
AWARD FOR BEING A HARDENED
TARGET.
GREG AND I HAVE BEEN BACK AND
FORTH ON THIS, BUT WE KNOW MANY
SITES WITH OR HAVE BEEN
SHOOTINGS, THERE WERE ARMED
GUARDS.
THE KEY FOR ME HERE.
>> Greg: THREE.
A >> Juan: I THINK THERE IS
MORE THAN THAT.
>> Kimberly: DID THEY HAVE
METAL DETECTORS AND MAKE SURE
THERE WAS ONE POINT OF ENTRY?
>> Juan: NO, MY POINT IS WE
ARE LOOKING FOR EVERYTHING.
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT FOLKS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
THEY TALK ABOUT THIS GUY IS A
BAD GUY, GANG MEMBER, WHATEVER
OR HE HAD A GRUDGE OR HE WAS A
STALKER.
THE FACT IS, THERE'S TOO MANY
GUNS IN THE COUNTRY.
BUT NOW IN MEDIA PLACES ARE
GOVERNMENT OFFICES, WE PAY TO
PROTECT PEOPLE.
WHY DON'T WE SAY AS AMERICANS,
MORE THAN ONE GUN FOR EVERY
PERSON.
THIS KID GETS HIS DAD'S GUN.
THE GUY IN CONNECTICUT GOT HIS
MOM'S GONE.
>> Greg: YOU WERE GOING
FORWARD TO PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS
AND THEN YOU GO BACK TO TOO MANY
GUNS.
>> Juan: IT'S IMPRACTICAL TO
TALK ABOUT GUNS?
>> Greg: WHEN YOU SAY THAT
THERE'S TOO MANY GUNS, THAT'S A
BLANKET STATEMENT THAT DOESN'T
APPLY.
>> Dana: IMAGINE IF YOU DIDN'T
GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE THERE'S TOO
MANY GUNS.
YOU WILL NEVER GO TO SCHOOL
AGAIN.
ALL THE THINGS KIMBERLY
SUGGESTED.
LET'S SAY MAYBE THERE WAS A WAY
TO HAVE A COMPROMISE.
WHAT'S JUAN IS SUGGESTING
THERE'S TOO MANY GUNS.
IN THE MEANTIME, IF YOU WANT
YOUR CHILDREN TO BE SAFE AT
SCHOOL, THE THINGS KIMBERLY LAID
OUT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
>> Greg: THERE ARE WAYS TO TAG
IT IS ACTUALLY TAKING GUNS AWAY.
>> Jesse: A LOT OF DEADLY
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS HAVE HAPPENED
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS.
THAT'S JUST THE TRUTH.
BUT THE AMOUNT OF GUNS IN THE
COUNTRY HASN'T QUADRUPLED.
IT'S BEEN RELATIVELY STEADY, AND
THERE HASN'T BEEN A MASSIVE
DEREGULATION OF GUN LAWS.
WHAT HAS CHANGED?
GREG, YOU ARE RIGHT.
THERE IS A COLUMBINE COPYCAT
SITUATION.
THE RISE OF SOCIAL MEDIA AND
THE iPHONE.
THE OVER PRESCRIPTION OF
PSYCHIATRIC DRUGS FOR TEENS.
THE PROMISE PROGRAM,
CYBERBULLYING.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO
CRIMINALIZE CRIMINAL KIDS.
THE POLLS SAY 57% OF THIS
COUNTRY THINKS IT'S A MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE.
ONLY 20 OR SO PERCENT BELIEVE
IT'S A GUN-CONTROL ISSUE.
MOST PEOPLE DO WANT STRICTER GUN
CONTROL.
THE TWO THINGS THEY WANT: NUMBER
ONE, STRICTER BACKGROUND CHECKS
AND NUMBER TWO, MORE MONEY SPENT
ON MENTAL HEALTH SCREENINGS.
TO DEMONIZE THE NRA IS A
POLITICAL SOLUTION BUT NOT A
PRACTICAL SOLUTION.
NRA MEMBERS AREN'T MASKED
SHOOTERS.
THEY USUALLY NEUTRALIZE MASKED
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND THE LABOR
UNIONS SPEND MORE MONEY LOBBYING
THEN DOES THE NRA.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT GUN CONTROL,
THEY HAVE THE HOUSE AND SENATE
FOR TWO YEARS UNDER OBAMA, THEY
DIDN'T DO IT.
THE CITIES THAT HAVE THE
STRICTEST GUN CONTROL LAWS COME
USUALLY RUN BY DEMOCRAT MAYORS,
HAVE VERY HIGH RATES OF --
>> Juan: WHY DON'T REPUBLICANS
TAKE A STEP FROM EVERYBODY AT
THIS TABLE AND SAY WE AGREE.
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE ARE GOING TO DO BETTER ON
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WE ARE GOING TO NOT ALLOW PEOPLE
TO YOUNG.
>> Greg: THAT WOULDN'T HAVE
PREVENTED THIS.
>> Juan: THE IDEA, YOU CAN
ALWAYS SAY IT WOULDN'T HAVE
PREVENTED THIS ONE BUT WE CAN DO